is jeff bezos running for president
jeff bezos
i never heard that man i never seen him
tweet before i didn't know he had a
twitter account until like a year ago
and then all of a sudden he started you
know oh maybe this twitter thing could
be cool and at first my thought process
was oh he sees elon musk his uh arch
nemesis uh in the space race uh and on
the world's richest man list
being cool on twitter and and getting a
lot of notoriety for that so he's just
trying to get in on the fun and you know
jeff bezos thinks it might be cool to
get on twitter as well
now
bezos v biden
president biden tweeted my message to
the company's running gas stations and
setting prices at the pump is simple
this is a time of war and global apparel
bring down the price you are charging at
the pump to reflect the cost you're
paying for the product and do it now
sounds a little dictatorship
and then bezos
inflation is far too important a problem
for the white house to keep making
statements like this it's either
straight ahead misdirection or a deep
understanding of basic market dynamics
now
the first question is does president
biden write his own tweets no no okay
do we think that they unders they
misunderstand market dynamics
or it's misdirection i i don't
understand how
if you're president any president right
not even just him you could let someone
write something like that in such a tone
like that without approving those things
like i would never let someone write
that under my name i'd be like get the
hell out of here you're fired you're an
idiot that he knows that tweet went out
i don't know right i think he knows now
yeah
they're like bezos responding to your
tweet he's like what tweet yeah yeah
so
i don't know how the tweet gets written
or if he knows it's going out or not i
agree
completely tone deaf uh
i actually think it's both i think they
don't understand market dynamics and
they're trying to conduct misdirection
yeah it's not an either or it's a both
situation where they understand just
enough
to be dangerous in claiming things like
oh there's price gouging
but at the same time uh
there's just
complete misunderstanding of market
dynamics i mean they've been doing this
since the pandemic right yeah did they
send out the july fourth tweet this
because you're not year 10 cents anymore
now you're paying 8.6 more it's 17 for
the uh for the july 4th cookout 17 more
than last year oh yeah they definitely
inflation only 8.6 have no fear yeah
they're they're definitely not uh gonna
uh tweet that one out yeah i saw uh i
think it was fenn henrik uh or i think
it was him uh said you know first it
started with when this administration
came in they blamed trump and i think a
lot of people were like hey that's what
every politician does is they get into
office and all the problems they blame
on the last person right okay fine
that's part of the game whether you
agree or not part of the game then it
was like oh now we're going to blame
kovid it's like uh okay that happened
that was a thing the first time we all
lived through that like i guess that's a
thing
then they started to blame uh
putin and russia putin's price hike then
they started to uh blame the oil
companies and there's in the oil
companies were being uh price gouging
and they were taking advantage of the
situation and now with this tweet
they're literally blaming like the mom
and pop gas station down the street
and bring down your prices now which
just feels like it's a problem and
rather than play the blame game
let's just say hey we have a problem we
have to solve the problem and the
problem is not that the local gas
station is jacking their prices up
because you can drive down the street
and how did every gas station are they
on an email list and they all decided to
raise their prices about the same
percentage all at the same time not only
that but there's a it's competitive
right so you're actually incentivized to
lower them to some degree so people come
to your gas station right if there's
four on a block which one do you go to
usually it's the one that's the cheapest
the thing i worry is that they're gonna
start talking about price controls if
inflation doesn't come down which we see
in places like argentina and elsewhere i
think in argentina i forget the exact
numbers but there's like 1200 items that
are sold like consumer goods where
they're government-mandated price
controls yeah they say you cannot charge
more than this so what does a company do
if
if we get to this situation like that
where there's price controls and you
start taking a loss on a product because
you literally are not making money on do
you just stop you just stop selling it
right
this is this is pretty easy the
government says that i'm losing money on
we and selling them if the government
says uh hey you know that gallon of milk
that cost you three dollars to buy as at
your uh uh kind of your wholesaler we
only want you to sell it for two dollars
and 80 cents guess what you do you don't
source the milk anymore right and then
guess what that leads to price controls
usually lead to a lack of supplies
because people just say i'm not getting
that i'm not gonna you can't mandate me
to lose money well the only price
control that's really gonna work are on
things that people a hundred percent
need you can't press control can you
people just stop eating it candy here's
a uh here's a good one right what are
the the lowest margin businesses you can
think of right grocery stores and gas
stations
grocery stores
grocery stores operate at 2.5 percent
average margin price gouging yeah
grocery shops are 2.5
next are car dealerships uh which are
slightly higher than that so it's
actually car dealerships at 3.2 percent
they make most of their money on the
service centers and stuff like that then
it's grocery stores are 2.5 percent and
the lowest is gas stations at 1.4
percent gasoline fuel 1.4 on fuel on
fuel yeah somebody in the chat said that
uh you want to know why gas prices are
uh uh are so high just in in like a
normal state not in high inflation
well a lot of the cost is taxation yeah
they tax it at every single point that
they possibly can right and so if you
were to take out all that taxes you want
to drive down the cost of gasoline for
people to buy
literally remove all the taxes on
gasoline now again that would cause a
chain reaction there would be less
revenue and there would be problems and
whatever but at the end of the day what
we have is market intervention
market intervention throws off the free
market when you throw off the free
market then people try to self-correct
as they try to self-correct then people
intervene again and it becomes a whole
problem and we get situations like we
are in right now do you ever think
that like 20 or 30 years from now
there's some person who's gonna be like
40-year high inflation in the united
states back in the 2020s
and they're gonna like go on the
internet and they're gonna find a video
like this and they're like these guys
were talking about price controls
before they had price controls
they were talking about how stupid
all of these policies don't ever see
before the bill comes yeah i mean like
like that's literally when i go back and
i uh look at like take the early 1980s
and you go back and you look
the information at the time was in
newspapers or it was uh um in many cases
private communication somebody wrote a
letter to somebody or or whatever right
they didn't have this you can go on the
internet today if you search the word
inflation on twitter
historians are going to have a field day
they're going to look at uh look at
cryptocat74321 they were all over the
inflation game
they nailed it but that's what's going
to happen right is that now because
people share all their thoughts online
at all times you can go back and you can
see exactly what was happening yeah
people used to have to find news paper
clippings and like yeah it's just not
this is the newspaper there's also a lot
of bad thoughts on the internet of
course 100 percent it works both ways
there was bad thoughts in the newspaper
50 years ago
yeah people saying the internet wasn't
going to work you could argue that
there's even worse thoughts in the
papers today right but as you look
through this it ends up being the same
exact uh situation over and over and
over again is usually the people on the
ground the people with skin in the game
they know that inflation is happening
they see it
go to the grocery store and it is
obvious
go try to buy certain things to cook out
for july 4th last year to this year it's
up 17
there's people who walked into a grocery
store over the weekend and said i'm
going to get some charcoal i'm going to
get some ketchup mustard hot dogs
hamburgers all stuff and they got to the
register and they said holy [ __ ]
if you don't believe inflation's real i
would suggest going to a local mom and
pop not a franchise restaurant and just
ask them and they'll probably be very
very open with you and just be like hey
how much are your prices up what are you
paying more for you i guarantee they're
like we're paying more for x y and z and
that's why the price on our menu is up
you want to know what a uh a milestone i
have in my head is
i call it the urban hundred dollars and
the rule 50
and my whole idea is once we breach
those two things for the average meal
eating out
not gonna be pretty because people then
people are gonna get pissed right like
they're they're mad about other things
whatever but if you and somebody else
two people go to dinner right now i
think gas is already at that level of
some sort right like that's a
psychological thing for a lot of people
how much it takes to fill up their tank
uh for people who obviously drive every
day and stuff like that they have a
number in their head that they've been
paying for potentially years to some
degree or at least a range and once it
gets over certain amounts it really hits
you with this shock factor of like holy
[ __ ] that's a lot more than i was paying
a year ago or two years ago or three
years ago so i think to your point like
it's things that are a psychological
barriers right whether it's eating out
whether it's gas whether it's groceries
stuff like that those are the things
where people start to get concerned if
you live outside a major city you go and
like you and your significant other just
the two of you get dinner and it's 50
bucks people gonna riot yeah they're not
gonna be happy already i would argue
already if you go to dinner in cities
miami new york l.a right those types of
places if you're not going like a fast
food place you're just going to kind of
a
normal sit down you know not kind of
like a uh not like a qsr but yeah yeah
and but also not like a super expensive
whatever
it may not be 100 yet but it's pushing
close it's pretty close right i mean you
sit down the meal is you know 30 bucks
you get an appetizer you each get a
drink and and you get uh two entrees
you're at 120. listen you got to be a
genius plus tip right like you got to be
like you're getting there yeah and so
now all of a sudden you start getting
people being like
no
i'm not gonna go there i'm not gonna do
that
and so as they tighten financial
conditions if prices stay up like that
people are gonna have less money they're
gonna start making decisions it's gonna
pull a lot of pressure on those types of
businesses
come back to the last point before dylan
joins us is jeff bezos is going to run
for president
he's been doing a lot more political
talk since he stepped down from amazon
the timeline would add up stepping down
from amazon giving him time to kind of
figure out his campaign is that a tesla
did he just test
whether people are receptive to his
message
i mean his message was very clear and
very nice jeff bezos
uh uh what's he bill gurley he retweeted
him afterwards because bill tweeted and
was like this doesn't have anything to
do with politics you know we need to be
sensible about this stuff everyone wants
to believe in science this is math or
whatever and he retweeted that which i
thought was interesting because he was
clearly basically playing defensive then
at that point of like guys look i'm not
saying pro-republican pro-democrat like
i'm just you know saying what i think if
jeff bezos runs for president and his
whole platform
is just stop the nonsense
facts
facts right let's put those in air
quotes who knows what facts are today
but just says we are going to take a
straightforward approach and i'm gonna
run the united states of america like a
business
he wins hands down like clean sweep see
ya there's not a single politician who
gets up there and even has a shot oh
yeah he would uh absolutely win it would
be a massacre why because but i don't
think he's been
because he's saying because the first
thing he says is i understand
how to have you press a button on your
phone and something shows up before the
end of the day
guess what i'm gonna do to health care
guess what i'm gonna do to the post
office
guess what i'm gonna do that it goes up
against anyone on stage i built a
trillion dollar company
what have you done i employ a million
people i have created 100 plus thousand
millionaires between shareholders
employees etc
explain to me how you are going to run
the economy more efficiently or
effectively than me
someone made a good point he's too smart
to run for president yeah i don't think
he's gonna run because
although he is like flashy to some
degree right he's in the the tabloids
you know the parties
he's got the yachts
he hasn't he's not really like uh that
public facing actually if you really
think about it right he just started
tweeting but he doesn't do a bunch of
these conferences
like
maybe but you would think like with
trump it was kind of obvious like he
loved that [ __ ]
you know i mean like you could see that
i would pay
i might pay a thousand dollar
pay-per-view
bezos versus trump in a one-on-one
debate dude bezos would wipe the floor
with him can you imagine in a debate
those two i mean trump would just call
them names that's what i'm saying
well the way that we're gonna get her
clean mr queen
but the way that we're gonna get down
the cost of goods being shipped across
america blah whatever and trump would be
like it's a giant you own the washington
post
but but that's my point that's why i
don't think he would do it like that's a
waste of time
he's like dude how crazy is that we're
talking about somebody who literally our
reaction is that it would be a waste of
time for him to be the president of the
united states debating against certain
people yeah but i mean i don't think
it's a waste of time for him to be
president
could he
improve america to the point where uh in
one presidential uh period we would look
back and be like wow this is probably
the most progress we've ever made as a
country
tough to tell right i think he'd
obviously advance certain things right
uh uh entrepreneurship they might lower
some taxes i don't know but uh yeah i
mean look he obviously has the
experience i think that's the most
important thing when you when you think
about people outside of uh government
that have experience to do these types
of things or are qualified to do these
types of things yacht taxes would drop
off the freaking cliff
yeah
the the uh the last thing that i'll say
is uh if um
bezos ran
you know what i think he should do
just go get like i don't know andy jassy
or like just go get somebody else who
worked at amazon who was like an
executive and be like we're gonna amaz
amazonify
america we're gonna make it super
official we're gonna drive costs down
we're gonna improve your life like we're
customer-centric like do all this stuff
and people be like what do you mean he's
like well i'm just going to bring my
whole team from ambassador yeah we're
going to take the executive team we're
going to put them in place and there are
some people on the internet who would
freak out they would be so mad i don't
know man andy jazzy better be holding on
for his seat he's gonna be he needs a
new job
amazon stocks down 35 since he took over
listen listen he's got a little rocky
road yeah i'm just saying basically
jesse's gonna be uh positioning for vp
before he has to get fired as soon as
he's like hey man i own a lot of shares
still i need you to chill with the whole
tank in the stock thing trying to buy a
new yacht book is down and tom
zuckerberg ain't going anywhere yeah of
course
the last thing i'll say about this
before we uh bring dylan is uh when i
saw bezos tweeting at uh at biden uh
obviously i was laughing many of these
thoughts i was having whatever right now
it's like these two guys like imagine uh
bezos and biden debating each other
right uh is i saw somebody respond and
say like uh yo chief how about you get
the washington post to start talking
about this stuff yeah
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time